Virginia governor Glenn Younkin is now
demanding an investigation into the top
high school in the country after
allegations that it withheld telling
students about a prestigious award this
is all in the name of equity by the way
Thomas Jefferson High School in Fairfax
County Virginia known as a school for
gifted and talented students is
admitting that numerous National Merit
Scholars were only told of their honor
after important college application
deadlines had already passed but my next
guest is a parent of one of those
students is saying that the director of
student services told her that it was
done intentionally because he and the
principal didn't want to hurt the
feelings of students who didn't get the
award oh my God Jordan Lee now is Shawna
ishar Thomas Jefferson High School mom
Shawna I know you're a proud mother of a
great
son who's a senior at the school doesn't
want to hurt the feelings of students
who did I mean that's such a prestigious
honor to be a National Merit scholar not
everyone can be there right we were so
proud of him when we found you know the
certificate was in his room and a pile
of papers and we asked him you know what
was this and the thing Laura that really
makes me so sad is that these kids at
the school do amazing accomplishments
and the school doesn't celebrate them to
the level that these kids deserve and as
such these kids are thinking that their
accomplishments don't mean anything but
it does mean a whole lot I mean
graduating in the top three percent of
your class in terms of s.a.t PSAT scores
is a huge honor and we should be
celebrating the kids for that not trying
to hide that information well you know
we had heard over the last couple of
years since really since the George
Floyd tragedy that you know the the
concern about making other people feel
bad because they're not in high honors
or they're not an honor so they didn't
get an AP designation or they didn't do
well on a on an exam even what does that
do to objective standards in the United
States oh it absolutely destroys it
right I mean these kids are are thinking
that you know that their accomplishments
don't mean anything what does it do to
the kids who who are coming up through
the ranks or maybe are improving over
time why bother trying really absolutely
not trying I mean why would you I mean
these Awards don't mean anything to you
your accolades don't mean anything to
you you're led to believe that you know
college admissions don't even look at
SAT and ACT scores anymore why are you
even working on your studies I mean it's
just a hodgepodge of luck at this point
and at this point what are the kids at
TJ say about how this is all going and
they kind of know what's going on do
they not yeah they are I mean my son and
his friends have have made comments that
they really are proud of the work that
I'm doing and some of the other parents
are doing to try to make the school
better they were really proud when they
got accepted to this school I mean it's
one of the top it is one let me just
tell everybody watching it's one of the
top schools in the United States period
Thomas Jefferson Heights but that that
made them feel bad or it's not fair to
the other kids who didn't get in I've
never heard of anything more ridiculous
I don't think it made any of them feel
bad I don't think these kids actually
felt bad I think it's talking about the
administration illustrators feel bad or
they think the kids should feel bad and
they try to to impart those feelings
onto these children and that's just
really inappropriate your son doesn't
really deserve to go to a top school it
has to be given to someone who didn't do
as well Shawna thank you very much for
bringing this issue to light and we're
going to be following up on this thank
you so much good luck to your son thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else